we have another only fans chick that
showed up to class naked
now guys I'd like to say I mean I think
I think it's clear when we do this kind
of stuff that some of this stuff is
staged some people do it for views like
we know this we live in a crazy world
um but this is why I say what comes
first do men ask for sex or do women beg
for attention and take off their clothes
I'm gonna argue over and over again that
women will take off their clothes before
men will ask for sex because it's like
you know the men will have their male
only spaces right they used to be male
only
um universities work
bars and the women will say lettuce and
let us know please oh please let us in
please please let us in and they'll say
Okay women
you can come all right come into the
schools come into the bars and then
we'll just slowly start taking our
clothes off and if we take off our
clothes and they say hey you're not
following dress code then we cry a river
and call them sexist it's like we can't
win
um and then we act like men taking off
their shirts is the same as us taking
off our shirts men don't have boobs are
you guys stupid like I don't and then
these feminists these wild feminists
will just cry about their oppression
because they can't get naked think about
that guys think of think about how silly
of a world this is we cry on the
internet because we can't get naked
that's how bad we want to get naked like
what
this is bad God like this is not this is
not I'm not proud of this you know
um and this is why as women we really
gotta understand that a lot of our the
way we feel is through emotion we want
to do something we feel like we should
be able to do it when a lot of times
um men telling us no is them protecting
us and this is the thing men they'll
just kind of let us be idiots they
really will because they don't want the
drama they don't want the trouble
they'll just let us go and if guys come
and say something to you usually they've
thought about it for a while usually you
know especially like guys in Authority
or that care about you
um
but you know we just don't listen we
don't listen efforts it's terrible
we can't y'all all came here to learn
correct yes yes
I don't care what she's wearing I just
want to do my presentation I'm running
out of time to do it no no do the
presentation
clothes so we can get on with this like
just put on some gym clothes or
something this is close yeah I can give
you my hood is that would that help
okay
I want to get you guys to show you the
simp did you see that simp in the back
he's like I don't care what she's
wearing [__]
you know she shouldn't be doing that
you know and now he's like well I I
don't care
really
and it's so silly it's like all these
guys I get so tired of it just tell us
what we want to hear because they either
don't want trouble or they want to get
laid he's like maybe I could get this
chick's number after
and when the truth of the matter is all
this [__] had to do was put some
clothes on that's it it's not that hard
um and honestly if if someone's saying
something to you about it is it really
that hard like just put on some pants or
go home learn from home stop torturing
out the rest of us with having to look
at your naked body I don't want to see
it I don't like I I you know what I was
thinking about I was thinking about
could it the men like okay if a guy
really wanted to be pure and he said I
want to wait till I'm married and I just
want to be a pure guy we don't have a
society that allows him to because
everywhere he goes these chicks are half
naked he goes to work they're half naked
he goes to the gym they're half naked he
goes outside they're half naked it's
like women we just keep taking off our
clothes I was thinking like men should
be able to like Sue women for ruining
their purity we can take them to court
if they assault us right shouldn't I
feel like the men should be able to go
to court for women that just get naked
in front of them for no reason yeah I
I'm serious guys because it's like
I'm just I just get really tired of this
I get really exhausted really tired